what is the impact of war in ukraine on
the economy and indeed the cost of
living well we've just got the verdict
from the oecd major economic body and
how the world is doing and i'm afraid
it's a slightly depressing story this
shows you global economic growth
forecast that they had last time around
so back in december this is what they
were forecasting for this year and for
next year but here's how those numbers
have just changed in their latest
forecast look at those bars latest
forecasts down both of them down
significantly especially this year three
percent this year 2.8 percent next year
for global growth that's actually the
weakest since 2009 so the weakest since
the financial crisis as a result of what
we're going through right now and if you
look specifically at all of the
different major countries the oecd is
basically a club of developed developed
economies so if you look at all of those
oecd nations including the uk there's
the uk in the middle the red bar have a
look at this this is this year the
forecast for this year's growth uk's
middle of the pack look at next year
we're going to just go through next year
look at the red bar down down down down
actually the uk with the weakest
economic growth of any oecd country in
2023 raising a question why is that well
here's the chief economist of the oecd
the uk
specific
again are
a very fast pace of monetary tightening
like in the u.s
a very
rapid fiscal consolidation
uh the seven after the u.s in the g7 but
the u.s had wider deficit
um and then
the brexit which is adding to this with
threat frictions so
all of these are obviously impacting
uk firms and citizens
so brexit but also extra fiscal
consolidation what does that mean it
means basically the uk is starting to do
a kind of austerity cutting back and the
oecd says it needs to potentially uh do
a little bit less of that but here's one
other thing that's worth pointing out
the gap between what richer and poorer
households are feeling in terms of the
cost of living squeeze well the red bars
here show you the inflation rate on food
and energy for those in low-income
households the blue bars are those those
in high-income households look the red
bars are a lot higher than the blue bars
but in particular in the uk in fact that
gap there between red and blue
low-income and high-income households is
the highest in the uk of any of these
countries
around the world just underlining that
for all the talk about leveling up there
are still
some very big gaps out there